seven that's the number seven seconds
that's how long it takes for your
audience decide whether they're gonna
pay attention now that I hopefully have
your attention we're gonna talk about
the book as we speak
our presentation today will follow the
classic narrative structure it'll have a
beginning a middle and an end
begin with we start with the ramp or the
road map which is what we're doing right
now I bring you up to speed and let you
know where we're going next my
colleagues will each discuss a point of
discovery first content next delivery
and then state after this we'll move on
to question an answer
well we'll answer your insightful and
probing questions about the material we
just covered and then finally dessert
will serve you something sweet and
delicious
well now that I've shown you the way off
we go the first thing to master for
high-performance communication is
content listeners often complain that
the information is too long is not
relevant or there is no point in the
information the listener naturally has a
tendency to not care much about what the
speaker has to say but rather cares
about what's in store for him therefore
two must content emphasize on three
things first the preparation second
architecture and third is the technique
talking about preparation preparation
for a presentation is similar to that of
a dinner you want the audience to go
away with an impact with an experience
not just with the meal ask yourself
three questions first of all what do you
want the audience to do that is the
outcome why should they care that is
relevance and what is the point that is
the message we want to architecture an
effective communication has a design
similar to an opera or a movie a
presentation has three parts the
the middle and the end how many of you
think it is thickening that is more
important and how many of you think it
is the end that is more valuable yeah
majority of you think it's either the
beginning or the end that is more
important yet when you prepare our
presentation we focus majority of the
time on the middle a strong beginning
leans the audience into the presentation
whereas a strong and impactful end
leaves the audience with the emotions
needed to take action and finally going
on to techniques an average person
speaks about 7,000 words a day therefore
by the time your listener goes to bed he
has forgotten most of the words that you
spoke therefore the three traditional
techniques for high performance
communication are storytelling audience
love stories no matter what the hell
they are
second is metaphor metaphor helps to
create a visual image of an idea in the
minds of an audience and it leaves a
lasting and long lasting impact and
third as Jerry always says active and
plain English it's better than complex
business jargon because simple words
have more power if you really want to
have power you need to focus on delivery
delivery is the art of expression we all
have three instruments that we can use
to be at the curve of colorful message
voice posture and movement face and eyes
our voice reveal what we are not saying
but we can craft our voice by focusing
on our breath and our vocal variety if
you still remember Ken's workshop he
made us say his message was that our
breath carries our voice and in order to
speak we need to really breathe in first
and we have vocal variety we can use
tempo we can talk really
very very very very very fast but yours
the most important sound silence just to
highlight our message we can talk really
low very authorative like The Godfather
or we can go very very high be at
empathy with the audience like talking
to a baby we can also use volume be
unpredictable with your voice
you can practice you can read bedtime
stories to your children before they go
to bed or you can just read poems to
your partner the second thing is posture
and movement it needs to be congruent
with your body and your message so try
to avoid any t-rex dish moves the
fig-leaf getting busted or you know I
don't care I'm gonna be out of your body
double try to come in stop breathe take
a heroic neutral position try to lean
forward a little bit like you're about
to give a gift to the audience the third
thing is your face and your eyes the
most important thing you are wearing is
actually your expression and to ever
smile is much cheaper than to change
your entire wardrobe you also need to be
at eye contact engage with the audience
don't scan don't get them dizzy because
the audience is always looking wherever
you are looking so we have three
instruments we have our voice posture
and movement and a face and eyes to
deliver a colorful message but now I'm
going to tell you about the most
important part of communication your
state state is the condition you're in
when that presentation starts when you
first open the conference room door and
there are three aspects of our state
that we must be able to control our body
our minds eye and our beliefs
so body as Java just mentioned is
everything it's about your movements
your breathing your facial expressions
and personally I found that it's really
difficult to think about what my body is
doing when I'm so focused on my content
so what can we do make it a habit first
analyze the emotional state you should
be in so right now I'm thinking
confidence and then think what can I do
with my body to portray that and then do
that same thing every time you're about
to start a presentation so maybe I take
a deep breath and put my shoulders back
and if I do that every time I'll make a
habit to jumpstart my body into
presentation mode next let's talk about
your mind's eye your mind's eye is what
you're thinking about and as we all know
our minds tend to wander unfortunately
due to evolution our minds tend to
wander about negative things which is
good for safety but not so good for
positive thinking and that's why it's
important that we take careful
consideration of what we are focused on
so our minds typically focus by asking
ourselves all those internal questions
so when you're up in presentation you
may be thinking oh no what am I going to
forget is a skirt too tight what if they
don't like me and those are the
questions that are gonna drag us down so
what can you do ask a different question
instead think what gift can I bring to
my audience today what amazing takeaways
are they gonna have how much are they
gonna love me and those questions will
help you to refocus your minds I finally
let's talk about beliefs beliefs are the
lens through which we view everything in
the world if you've stood before an
audience and had a sinking feeling in
your stomach and gotten really nervous
chances are it was your beliefs and not
the audience itself that caused those
knots because the thing about beliefs is
for you they're always true think of
beliefs like a stool and stools are held
up by legs and in this case we'll call
those references so if you approach the
stage and you have the belief that my
audience is judging me then as you scan
gonna see someone yawning someone on
their cellphone someone talking in their
neighborhood that person scowling at me
and all of a sudden you have reinforced
that belief for yourself and as you move
through your life as you go on you're
going to continue to reinforce that and
then 20 years later you'll realize I've
always believed this because of what I
started believing back then but I bet
that if instead you decide to have the
belief my audience is incredibly engaged
and excited to hear what I have to say
you'll be able to find just as many
references to support that point so it
is imperative that we first of all
question our beliefs that we've
developed over time and second put in
place those positive beliefs that will
ensure our success and who doesn't want
to be successful in their presentations
well to ensure success follow the three
triangles content delivery state and
content we talked about preparation and
focusing on what you want your audience
to do we talked about architecture and
how a strong beginning and a powerful
ending really draws out emotions in your
audience we talked about technique
storytelling metaphor an active plain
language which has a lasting impact on
your audience next triangle is delivery
where we talked about your voice which
reveals what you're not saying we talked
about posture and movement and how it
needs to be congruent with your message
we talked about your face and your eyes
and how they're the most important thing
you wear to a presentation lastly we
talked about the state first we talked
about your body and how your posture and
your movement and the way you breathe
use facial expressions and muscles and
hand gestures all impact the delivery of
your message we talked about your mind's
eye and how what you focus on impacts
how you feel and we talked about beliefs
and how about what you believe about
yourself as a presenter will impact how
you show up so
content delivery state which triangle do
you find the most difficult to perfect
and why or what other questions do you
have for us thank you